but first tonight we turn to two of the
worst candidates ever to run for
president
now after dodging a very serious sexual
assault allegation for over a month
while today Joe Biden teamed up with
none other and Hillary Clinton they had
a town hall focusing on women's issues
you can't even make this up now of
course Hillary Clinton has quite a track
record on women's issues notably let's
see helping enabling some would say her
husband in numerous cover up sexual
misconduct allegations during his
political career and taking millions and
millions of millions of dollars from
countries that abuse women
and now coincidentally enough during the
virtual town hall on women's issues the
very credible sexual assault allegation
against Biden it didn't come up once
instead Hillary Clinton Joe Biden they
focused on other issues let's take a
look he was getting ready to go to a
junior high school dance and he didn't
have any cuff links and so his very
creative mother gene got him a nut and
bolt and made a pair of cuff links for
him but I think he said he was mortified
by that and he's told her that and she
just looked at him and she said Joey if
somebody says something to you about
your cuff links you just say what you
don't have a pair like that okay Joey
ultimately after they got some awkward
small talk out of the way Hillary
Clinton enthusiastically finally jumped
on the Biden Express he became very
sleepy though took a long time take a
look I want to add my voice to the many
who have endorsed you to be our
president just think of what a
difference it would make right now if we
had a president who not only listened to
the science but facts / fiction but
brought us together Oh time for Joe's
nap rare moment of honesty Hillary
Clinton like many other top Democrats
they shared her favorite part about the
coronavirus is there a favorite part
really oh for her and so many Liberal
Democrats all the opportunity never let
a crisis go to waste
- shove universal healthcare down the
throats of we the American people take a
look it needs to be part of a much
larger system than eventually and
quickly I hope gives us to universal
health care so I I can only say amen to
everything you're saying but also to
again enlist people that this would be a
terrible crisis to waste as the old
saying goes we've learned a lot about
what our absolute frailties are in our
country when it comes to health justice
and economic justice so you know let's
be resolved that we're gonna solve those
once you're elected president I promise
you asking me my objective lot energy
there to recap virtual Town Hall
supposedly focused on women in the
middle of a national emergency pandemic
Hillary Clinton bragging how kovat 19
could help Democrats politically Joe by
the way said the same thing very similar
himself she never once brought up the
very serious and credible sexual assault
allegations against Biden instead she
enthusiastically endorsed him now
remember it was Hillary she did say
sexual assault victims have a right to
be believed we'll talk about the I
believers in a second but let's go down
memory lane I want to send a message to
every survivor of sexual assault
don't let anyone silence your voice you
have a right to be heard and you have a
right to be believed
we're with you believe wanita Broderick
Kathleen Willey Paula Jones
what changed Hillary were you lying for
political gain well today's Biden's
accuser woman by the name of Tara Reid
foxnews.com she tells Clinton is
enabling a sexual predator
keep in mind Reid is a lifelong Democrat
she voted for Hillary Clinton she was a
staunch supporter of Barack Obama so
much so that she never went public with
this damning information about his
running mate
and as of tonight Reid's allegations
have been corroborated now by at least
four individuals that she confided in
shortly after the incident in 1993 a
mother even calling
into Larry King Live at the time to ask
for advice Tara Reid has filed a
criminal police report and get this
according to the Daily Caller Tara Reid
is now calling on Joe Biden to release
personnel records from his Senate office
that she believes will contain a copy of
her official complaint about the
incident so is Joe gonna be transparent
or release those records or are they
being Hilary as we speak
magically bleach pitted and disappearing
and will anyone in the Democratic Party
or the mob and the media well that's
right all these Democratic potential VP
candidates this weekend they weren't
asked the question about it
are they going to ask him about these
accusations
yesterday we reached out for comment
from Biden's potential Drummond running
mates he says he's picking a woman all
women to date many have not addressed
Reid's allegations directly let's say
including senator Amy Klobuchar who
apparently has no real courage
whatsoever Stacey Abrams gave a
wholeheartedly big defensive Biden today
saying that Joe will make women proud
and then there's senator Kirsten
Gillibrand according to NBC News the
morally bankrupt senator from New York
told reporters quote I stand by Vice
President Biden he's devoted his life to
supporting women and he has vehemently
denied this allegation in 2018 the
two-faced senator from New York said
that she believed Kavanaugh his accuser
she had no corroborating evidence no
witnesses and still Gillibrand indicated
that Cavanaugh has denials didn't even
matter she called for his nomination to
be withdrawn Oh what changed senator
Gillibrand it's like the media didn't
they protect quid pro quo Joe anyway
come to think of it what happened to all
the I believe errs where are the I
believers remember this I believe her
listen first of all anybody who comes
forward at this point to be prepared to
testify in the United States Senate
against someone who is being nominated
to one of the most powerful positions in
the United State
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed let me just say
right at the outset I believe dr. Ford I
believe the survivor here there's every
reason to believe her she has come
forward courageously and bravely I
believe her I stand with her she should
be bullied into this scenario where it's
a he-said she-said I believe professor
Ford I think she's credible and I think
when the investigation is finished and
when she testifies and judge Calvin what
testifies I think a majority of senators
will find her credible hey i believers
do you believe Tara Reid now remember
that allegation with Professor Ford was
an allegation with zero corroboration
zero witnesses no police report Tara
Reid check check check check check
hypocrisy reeks over in the House
Speaker Pelosi once praised the coverage
of Cavanaugh's accuser but is now
refusing to say anything about Tara Reid
she's supporting Biden this week
meanwhile more sadly of course
predictable hypocrisy from the mob in
your media Washington Post reported
quote developments in allegations
against Biden amplify efforts to
question his behavior okay let's compare
that word salad to this headline about
Kavanagh quote calls for justice
Kavanagh is impeachment or mounting
here's how it could work that looked
like fair balance journalism from Eric
pimples Washington Post I don't think so
of course not this is the constant
deception that is hurting our country we
have an information crisis in America
and the mob and the media they are
nothing more than state-run TV
propaganda of the extreme radical
Democratic Socialist Party and all
things hate Donald Trump every second
minute hour of every day
and tonight they're trying harder than
ever to prop up somebody who well
struggling to say it charitably probably
the worst
was corrupt inept candidate in history